I'm looking to the Future and I'll save
this for after the movie comes out so we
do get a villain tease at the end of the
movie but what about in terms of the
Turtles coming of age Journey do you
have any like you know hopes or or like
dream scenarios in terms of what the
next phase of that coming of age Journey
needs to be what they need to learn next
yeah I had a teacher in in high school
that told me like freshmen know nothing
and know they know nothing sophomores
know nothing but think they know
something Juniors know something but
think they know nothing and seniors know
something and know they know nothing and
I'm like I think they just went through
the phase where they don't really know
anything and they're kind of aware of it
and I think they're probably going to go
into a new movie with a lot of uh uh
confidence that will then be uh tested
uh uh by the world and by the the social
uh ecosystem of uh High School oh I love
that blueprint so so much also because
it sounds like there's a whole lot of
phase for men phases for many many more
movies and I'm here for it
congratulations thank you this is
exceptional oh thank you so much